[Music]
hello everyone
uh in the previous chapter on 2d
elasticity we had spent a considerable
amount of time
uh discussing various uh
problems within the broad paradigms of
plane stress
and plane strain so
plain stress and
plane strain
and if we quickly recall this plane
stress category of problems
this had to do with a very thin kind of
structures like plates
uh which had a certain uh kind of
loading
in plain loading and uh
and there are a number of other
conditions also here which had to be
satisfied
similarly for the plane strain we had to
deal with a certain kind of geometry
and a very specific kind of loading now
despite these rather restrictive
considerations we found out that
both this plane stress and plane strain
uh paradigms
they covered a lot of uh real
engineering structures all right so
uh so if you're interested in solving
various problems
uh involving beam like or plate like
structures
then then these two categories uh are
are sufficient to address those things
however you can you can imagine very
very easily that there are a number of
problems
which simply cannot be reduced
uh to these kinds of situations
uh be plain stress or plane stress
mainstream
there are huge number of problems which
can be reduced to these kinds
of uh situations but there are
even more number of problems which
simply cannot be reduced to either of
this
what then well for that we are going to
discuss
our current chapter of three-dimensional
elasticity
now uh you can easily also imagine
that uh when we are talking when you are
going to talk about
that the the more general category of
such 3d elasticity problems
then there there will be
a a huge number of different methods
which will be used to solve those
problems
okay many many different kinds of
methods now out of those methods
the one that will choose to discuss
within this context of 3d elasticity
chapter
is a one which will have a natural
connection with this 2d elasticity
chapter
so basically in 2d elasticity what we
did was we used the area stress function
approach
we used the ad stress function approach
and we had done a number of different
problems
with that and i'm sure that
many of the many of the term projects
that we're currently doing
uh is also based on these kinds of edu
stress function approach
so what we want to do in this 3d
elasticity chapter is that out of the
many different pro
kinds of methods that are available to
us we are going to choose a method
which has a direct connection with this
edit stress function approach
and that method is called the method of
potentials
a method of potentials
so what we'll see is that this method of
potentials
is kind of like the air stress function
but not quite and the ones that we
that we'll be focusing on so within this
method of potentials
uh there are number of different ways we
can we can proceed
in that method and the one and the
methods
the specific ways that we'll be taking
up
the main difference you will find with
the area stress function approach
is that while data stress function
directly represented the stresses the
sigma x6 the sigma x1 the sigma yy
or equivalently the sigma r the sigma r
heat and the sigma theta theta
what will happen is that in this method
of potentials
we are not going to consider at least
within the scope of
our studies in this chapter we are not
going to consider any stress potentials
although please note
that within the context of
three-dimensional elasticity and within
the specific context of method of
potentials
you you still very much have stress
potentials like the maxwell moreira
stress potential but will not take up
those
rather we'll be taking up the
displacement potentials
okay some of the displacement potentials
so that is uh so two main differences
with the previous chapter
first of all that we are going to talk
about 3d elasticity that is beyond the
scope of 2d elasticity
second is that we are going to talk
directly in terms of displacements
okay so uh
so this is about the method okay so
using these methods which
are uh which have a natural link with
the previous chapter
what are the kind of problems that we
can uh we can think of
you may i mean one may easily
start thinking that this is rather a
weird approach of of addressing
engineering problems
like you you learn a method and then you
go about finding problems
which will be solvable by this method
well uh
as it so happens that when we learn
some of the problems which can be solved
by these displacement potentials
we'll end up learning about the kind of
problems which have been historically
important in the development of
uh of engineering studies okay so
uh so for example so what what are the
kind
kinds of problems that can actually be
solved okay so
so in this introductory lecture i do not
want to go
and launch immediately into the into the
mathematical technicalities of these
displacement potentials
rather i want to expose you to uh to the
to the problems which serve as
motivating uh
basis for these studies okay so what are
the problems
so so one of the basic problems which
can be
solved and one of the earliest problems
also which was solved by these
displacement potentials
is uh is a situation like this
okay so what are the kind so this is the
question that we're that we're trying to
enhancing so what are the kind of
problems
that can be solved by this this is what
we're trying to answer here
let's go to the next page and discuss
this
so suppose you have an
a very very large three-dimensional body
okay so
for all effective purposes we can think
of it like in like an infinite body
and within this let's say that there is
a point
at which we are applying
a point loading a point force like this
okay so we have a specific point here
and at this point we are applying a
point loading
question is or the problem is that
what is the stress field around this
point as simple as that
it may sound simple to pose it like this
but
the solution to this and we'll do this
okay we will address this problem we'll
take up this problem
you'll see that it is not so
straightforward okay we will proceed by
the displacement potential and you'll
see that it's not so straightforward
okay in certain books you will find
that it it is it is presented the
solution is presented
uh in a rather uh
simplistic way okay i say simplistic and
not simple
because uh what they do is to provide
the the displacement potential and
uh do not say much about how that
displacement potential was arrived at
now that i think is a
is kind of hiding the real uh the real
challenges
which are which are associated with this
kind of a
problem okay so we'll try to expose
the real truth behind behind these kinds
of solutions
as much as possible another kind of
problem
is is suppose uh
so you understand this is a three
dimensional uh body so
we'll consider another three-dimensional
situation
where instead of this kind of a full
three-dimensional space
or three-dimensional body we consider it
like a half space
okay so so suppose we have uh
we have this kind of a situation
okay so you imagine that this
this entire three dimensional space has
been cut in half by plane
so that is the plane that is that is
exposed here
and you end up with uh
okay so this kind of a situation
okay and what you have here is that you
consider a point here
somewhere here and you consider a
point loading here
right and again the question is
that in the three-dimensional solid
which is present beneath this thing
uh beneath this plane what is the stress
state of stress
so all around this okay now uh
some of you may already be uh be
reminded
of the of the flemant problem which we
had addressed earlier
where we had a line loading and we could
think of it like it
we were able to reduce this thing to a
two dimensional situation we were able
to look at it from this side
so if you look go back and and look at
that lecture on the flamant problem
you'll see what i'm talking about
okay but this situation is quite
different okay although it may
seem that this is a simpler kind of
loading
compared to that line loading but
actually
because of the presence of this just a
point loading instead of a line loading
this is a proper three dimensional
problem okay
and the solution to this problem is
even more involved than this problem and
because of the historical
importance of this of these two problems
uh
and i say historical importance because
these are the kinds of
problems which turned out to be the
stepping stones
towards more involved uh problems
which led to solutions uh which had
which had
which had a direct relevance and
significance
for many many different kinds of
situations in mechanical engineering as
in
as well as in civil engineering okay
because of this historical importance
these problems
have are now known by the names
of of the of the scientists or
mathematicians
who first solved them so this problem is
the kelvins problem it's a famous
problem in
in elasticity
so this kelvin is the same kelvin which
you also have studied in your high
school physics
and and this problem this is
uh so so let's call this the three
dimensional
version of the flamant problem and this
is
actually bearing the name of bozenisk
so i i believe some of you have already
come across the name boozenisk in the
in the context of heat transfer studies
okay there are there is
a variant of this business problem also
so
suppose you have this kind of a
situation again
where when we have this this half space
okay and instead of this vertical point
loading
we have at this point
a horizontal loading which is along this
plane
okay so this is uh this is
uh referred to as
the cherokee's problem
okay hearing the name of cheruti
all right and as i mentioned already
these are the kinds of problems which
served as templates or stepping stones
towards more involved problems and
i i mentioned this in the context of of
our earlier discussions on the flemann
problem is that
these are the kind of problems which
actually led to
to studies to hardcore studies
uh in an entire different branch of
of or or in an entirely separate branch
of of uh of mechanics called contact
mechanics
okay and that is just one uh one example
there is an entire in that field uh
of study in in geology and geophysics
where also they have these kinds or the
applications of these things
again in civil engineering they have
applications of these
uh so these are fairly broad uh and very
very significant kind of problems and
these are the kinds of things which we
hope to
hope to be able to solve through through
the displacement
potential method now because these are
so involved
all these problems each of them are
quite involved
we'll see that uh will perhaps only be
able to uh
to address the kelvins problem in full
detail
okay uh and we'll see
what if we can discuss something uh
something
in us in a simplified fashion associated
with the business and the
charities problem all right now
uh before we uh before we again actually
launch into the technical
uh the mathematical technicalities uh
let's just uh
quickly state
what's the overall plan okay i have till
now
said that in the 2d elasticity chapter
we have used the addie stress function
and in this three day classes chapter we
are going to use the displacement
function
so the plan is like this that here
in the displacement potential method
what we are going to do basically
okay we are going to express
the displacement field
u vector in
terms of
some tailored
and vector potentials
actually this is not something
completely alien to you
because back in the kinematics chapter
we had already discussed that
suppose you have an irrotational
displacement field
then it is possible to express the the
displacement
as u is equal to u vector is equal to
grad of some phi
okay because uh when you take the curl
of that displacement field
uh the the curl of of the grad of pi
is identically zero so these are the
kinds of things that we want to discuss
here
furthermore please note that since we
are going to express the displacement
field in terms of some scalar vector
potentials
uh the the governing equation associated
with
the elasticity problems that we're going
to address uh
that will be expressed not in terms of
the stress equilibrium equations
rather what we'll do is we will we will
uh express the stress equilibrium
equations which is basically just this
equation
okay which is this equation which you
have come across so many times till now
starting from the from the stress
chapter uh
we are going to express this sigma
in terms of the linear elastic isotropic
material behavior which also you are all
familiar with
by now so
that is basically uh
if we write it in terms of the index
notation
like this so we are going to substitute
this thing here and of course we are
going to use this
and you have already done this this uh
this re-representation of the stress
equilibrium equations
in terms of the displacement fields so
when we do
this and furthermore this
ultimately what you will obtain is a
second
order differential equation a second
order
differential equation
in terms of
the displacement uh vector and you have
already done this
uh as part of the problem sheet on
material behavior
so i i advise you to to go back and take
a look at that equation uh
because time and again over the next few
lectures we are going to utilize
that equation okay so back when we were
using the edit stress function
we used directly the stress equilibrium
equations which was this
uh because uh because these
because this equation it is directly
satisfied by the
by the stress function representations
and we also
went on to use the compatibility
equations now we are going to use
this equation represented in terms of
the displacement
and the displacements in terms of the
potentials please note that in this
particular approach of this chapter
we are not going to need to to
to separately take uh
the compatibility equations the reason
is simple is that because
you are at from the very outset trying
to solve for the displacements
of course the the moment you you you
obtain the displacements
they are going to be compatible you
don't have to worry about the
compatibility separately
which was not the case in the previous
chapter because
uh you were trying to solve for the
stresses okay and from those stresses
you would be able to find out the
displacements
so you really had to worry whether the
whether your solution would be
compatible or not
and you had to embed the compatibility
equations
uh with this or combine the
compatibility equations with the stress
equilibrium equations
okay so we don't have to worry about the
compatibility
equation this time so so in terms of
difficulties
of of this chapter you you you lose some
you gain some and you'll see that the
specific details of it starting from the
next chapter
all right thank you very much